[Music]
when I say pickle Rick what is the first
thing that comes to your mind
be honest pickle Rick Isaac Newton
pickle rake Socrates pickle Rick Baker
Baker Mark Zuckerberg Becca wreck
JD berry the greatest creation of our
time of our generation this is what they
will speak up when they look back at our
tent today we're gonna play pickle brick
the game the game everybody they made a
game they made a game called pickle Rick
it's 100% approved by Adult Swim they
they made this game this game is made by
them
this game will cost you four dollars on
Steam here we go
I am pickle Rick it says thug life on me
excellent okay here's our first enemy
the ranked it says kill this is
incredible look at that oh my god the
graphic he doesn't know where I am now
this is just like pickle Rick there we
go the rat is kill it has merged with
the floor and there it is pickled brick
that's my name I'm pickle Rick press Q
or B to break vases oh my god just like
Dark Souls just like jojo's open chest
it's just like Dark Souls I have a sword
just let it's this doctors listen this
must be I feel I just feel my IQ points
going up every time now this is this is
what I'm talking about this is now this
is a soundtrack we recognize and let's
roll through these to break them as
instructed that doesn't seem to work
that's fine
this is just like half-life look at
these I'm gonna go in a stealth approach
here
as pickle Rick always though this is so
funny I can roll - just like Dark Soul
they don't seem to hit back this is the
hardcore adrenaline rush that I want
from video games truly inspirational
I've always wanted to be pickle Rick
because he always goes and pick a ring
so now I know what that feels like I'm
dead and the rat continues to stare at
the wall a resume resumes the game okay
[Music]
all right we got a great sword
now let's missing boys up look at that
just like pickle Rick whoa look at that
zombies crazy knock gum out
thug life am i right the sword is going
through my head wonderful I'm so glad
that I don't swim and the team of pig
Rick and Morty really put the time and
effort to make a decent game and not
just live off the mean live off the
franchise this is really what gamers
want there's a checkpoint here for some
reason I think we're ready for this bad
boy
this is peggle wreck I was trying to
this is far to him the better
maybe we can do a jump attack on this
guy I think we did it this does feel a
lot like Dark Souls okay you can't argue
against that here we are now in the
second level which we do recognize from
Rick and Morty itself you have
experienced a shipwreck just like pick a
Rick I mean Rick and Morty find
necessary tools or working ship to
escape this planet just like Rick and
Morty this game is on Steam we got a
lightsaber katana everyone excellent
wonderful you know all these their Dark
Souls clones that come out it's a shame
they should have just made this and not
even bother
we're fighting Zod aside words now just
like your wicked morning looks like
we're about to face some more enemies
it's the music not looping it's not
looking is it it's not limping it just
stops the music just stops which sends a
deeper meaning on how things just
doesn't go on forever everything has a
time set of things okay I'm a Rick and
Morty fan so you wouldn't really
understand if you it there we go we
killed another one of the cyborgs now
we're gonna continue our quest up here I
am having the time of my life there's no
other game I would rather play right now
this is it guys this is we this is
officially oh wow that looks like a lot
of enemies oh wow this is gonna be a
tough one for pickle Rick I wish we had
a save for one sing plug and put them
everywhere and Oh Ange two died man
that's tough man
it just okay it's a challenge this game
you know the developers didn't want it
to be easy which I can respect you know
and I lose my weapon apparently if I
respawn this is [ __ ] great all right
we're gonna do it we're gonna do a new
approach here since we don't have any
weapon because it just doesn't load your
weapon we're gonna we're gonna do a new
approach called you only live once a
once and it seems to be working just
fine
oh wow what I was quite the threat that
we had there let's continue while we
beat the level what level is going to
present itself next my god okay this is
nice this is nice your teleport has
broken but you really need to return
back to your own dimension yeah like how
the game tells me that find right
equipment and make sure that you can
leave okay all right okay are you an
enemy or hey buddy you need a ride like
a checkpoint right away that's just
great
this happens in Dark Souls 2 you try and
hit the goddamn monster but you keep
hitting that [ __ ] doorway and it's so
annoying this is just like Dark Souls
which I really appreciate you tell me
this is not like consoles okay you tell
me oh my god could you be wandering
aimlessly into an empty map or are you
going in the right path you know that's
that's the questions you ask yourself
well playing this game which sorta makes
you reflect on life as well are you just
wandering aimlessly or are you on the
right path in life and is that lens
flare going to [ __ ] [ __ ] it's so
annoying these stairs are very well
designed for pickle Rick they're so well
designed that it's truly an intellectual
challenge to enter these stairs
why would I walk up the stairs you might
ask yourself I mean the graph the
graphics is some of some of the best
we've ever seen
okay let's see if we can do a stealth
kill just like Dark Soul
you got a head on me
it doesn't matter because we are pickle
Rick I wish this lens flare would just
go away it's so annoying Wow look at
that
pickle rick has his interdimensional
rock walking through spell which is
great this game makes me question life
and why I'm living it oh great we have
to lens flares now fantastic scheme made
by JJ Abrams stop with the lens flare my
god oh wow
triple lens flare we've repeat literally
if you beat this game it takes 200 plus
IQ at least at least I need to prove
that I'm not just some fake Rick and
Morty fan come on Billy's there it is
just as I remember it my god finished
look at all Wow
oh the sweet euphoria this is it for now
but we are planning on adding more
levels are you kidding me you're you're
joking best game best game of all time
pickle a Rick everybody that was
incredible I am so glad and aren't you
glad too